[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لقي الاقتراح الروسي باخضاع
الاسلحه الكيميائيه السوريه الى الرقابه
الدوليه ترحيبا حذرا من العواصم الغربيه
فبينما رات فيه واشنطن ولندن وباريس ثمره
لضغوط المجتمع الدولي طالبت بشده باخضاع
لجداول زمنيه واضحه تمنع استغلاله للمبا
طله والتسويف نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه
في
محورين الى اي حد يمثل المقترح الروسي
بديلا عن الضربه العسكريه التي توعد الغرب
بتوجيهها للنظام
الاسد وما مصير مواقف الغرب تجاه الثوره
السوريه في ضوء ردود فعله على المقترح
الروسي
الاخير
جدل روسي غربي نشط اندلع بشان الصيغه التي
يمكن وفقها قبول اقتراح موسكو باخضاع
اسلحه دمشق الكيميائيه للرقابه الدوليه
فروسيا التي قفزت الى موقع المبادره فيما
يخص التطورات في سوريا لم تقبل اشتراطات
الغرب لقبول مقترحها بل سرعت هي في
المقابل الى فرض شروطها لتفعيل هذا
المقترح الذي اكدت انه لن يفعل الا بعيدا
عن البن السابع في الامم المتحده وبعد
اعلان واشنطن تراجعها عن ضرب نظام
الاسد ملف النزاع السوري ينتقل بتعقيدات
من تطور لاخر الخلفيه الان هي اقتراح
روسيا اخضاع الاسلحه الكيميائيه السوريه
للرقابه الدوليه الاقتراح جاء نتاجا
لاتصالات روسيه امريكيه يقول وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ويؤكد ان موسكو استفادت
من زياره وزير الخارجيه السوري الاخيره كي
تطرح عليه الم مبادره مع دراسه انضمام
سوريا لاتفاقيه حظر الاسلحه الكيميائيه
الرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما يرى ان
الاقتراح الروسي قد يكون تطورا ايجابيا في
النزاع ووصفه وزير الخارجيه جون كيري امام
اعضاء بالكونجرس بانه قد يكون الطريقه
المثلى للتخلص من تلك الاسلحه وان حذر من
صعوبه ذلك وقال ان واشنطن تنتظر تسلم
اقتراح واضح في هذا الصدد لكنها لن تنتظر
طويلا فرنسا التقطت راح واعتبرته فرصه يجب
انلا تفوت واعلن وزير خارجيتها السعي
باريس لاصدار قرار من مجلس الامن الدولي
بموجب الفصل السابع من ميثاق الامم
المتحده يدين احداث الغوطه وينص على
معاقبه المسؤولين ويطالب النظام بالكشف عن
ترسانته الكيميائيه ووضعها تحت السيطره
الدوليه توطئه لتفكيكها مع انذاره بعواقب
وخيمه اذا انتهك الالتزامات المترتبه عليه
بموجب القرار بريطانيا التي رفض مجلس
العموم فيها العمل العسكري ضد سوريا تحدثت
حكومتها عن عدم امكانيه تاجيل الرد على
احداث الغوطه لاجل غير مسمى وحملت روسيا
ونظام الاسد مسؤوليه اقناع العالم بجديه
الاقتراح واثار التفاصيل تتعلق بشكل
تنفيذه والسقف الزمني الذي يجب ان يتم فيه
ذلك وبين يدي الاقتراح الروسي والتعليقات
الحذره بخصوصه والمشروع الفرنسي الذي ترى
روسيا انه لا يمكن قبوله تطرح اسئله كثيره
بشان مصير الثوره السوريه التي تحذر
المعارضه من مغبه اختزالها في قضيه
الاسلحه الكيميائيه مع تجاهل الات القتل
الاخرى وما ارتكبه النظام من فظائع حسب
تعبيرها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي عبد الوهاب بدخان
كما ينضم الينا من واشنطن ستيف كليمنس
رئيس تحرير مجله ذ اتلانتك وكبير الباحثين
في مؤسسه امريكا الجديده اهلا بضيفي استاذ
عبد الوهاب كيف يمكن بدايه تفسير ما يجري
الان من جدل في مجلس الامن هل هو تاكيد
للمخاوف الغربيه من المبادره ومن القبول
بها اعتقد بان المبادره يعني ليست واضحه
حتى الان والكل حذر منها ثم ان روسيا لم
تتقدم بعد بالنص الرسمي للمبادره كي تطلع
عليه الدول الاخرى و وترى ماذا يمكن
تعديله او اذا كانت المبادره بحد ذاتها
مقبوله انما ال الجدل حول البند السادس
والبند السابع طبيعي لان روسيا منذ
البدايه اتخذت مثل هذا هذا الموقف ولكن
بنفس الوقت هناك تساؤلات ايضا عما اذا كان
تسليم
الاسلحه ي يعتبر اعترافا من النظام بشكل
غير مباشر بانه مسؤول عن مجزره الغوطه اي
وايضا اذا كان تسليم المخزون الكيمياوي
يعفي من معاقبه من ارتكب المجزره اي و
بطبيعه الحال روسيا تتبنى روايه النظام
السوري الذي يقول ان المعارضه هي
التي ارتكبت هذه المجزره وبنفس الوقت يعني
شددت اي
شدد النظام مع روسيا امس على انه يمكن
للمحققين ان يعودوا ويحقق في
اماكن يعني يفترض ان المعارضه ارتكبت فيها
مثل هذه الم سيد كليمنس على ماذا رحبت
الدول الغربيه فيما يتعلق بالمبادره
الروسيه اذا كانت اذا كان مضمون هذه
المبادره غير واضح وغير
محدد
اعتقد اننا سنرى كيف ان فرنسا والولايات
المتحده
وايضا الاطراف المعنيه الاخرى تتقدم بخطط
دقيقه ومفصله وفيها جداول زمنيه وتبدا
بالرد على بعض الاسئله التي طرحها زميلنا
ضيفكم في الاستديو اعتقد انه حاليا هناك
قدر ك من عدم الثقه في الولايات المتحده
تجاه المبادره الروسيه ومن الان فلاديمير
بوتين عقد المساله والعرض الروسي بقوله ان
على الولايات المتحده ان تسحب اعلانها او
تهديدها باستخدام عمل عسكري ضد سوريا لكي
تعمل مبادره موسكو وبالطبع هذا قد لا يحدث
اذا يحتاج الى درجه عاليه من الدقه
والوضوح وفي الوقت نفسه اداره اوباما
ستكون متعنت ومصره على اهميه بقاء خيار
استخدام القوه لان مثل هذا الخيار هو الذي
اوصلنا الى النقطه الحاليه والمبادره
الروسيه استاذ عبد الوهاب اذا كان الجانب
الروسي يؤكد بان هذه المبادره تمت
بالتنسيق مع الجانب الامريكي فما الذي غاب
ما الذي يفسر هذا الجدل اذا
ا اعتقد بان التنسيق لم يكن على التفاصيل
التنسيق كان ان المبا ان روسيا قالت ان
لديها مبادره يمكن ان
تتجنب يمكن تجنب الضربه العسكريه بواسطتها
والجانب الامريكي لم لم يمانع في ذلك لذلك
عندما طرحت طرح الموضوع على النظام السوري
ولا اعتقد ان الروس طلبوا من من من النظام
السوري ذلك بلطف انما قالوا له هذا ما يجب
ان ان ان يح يحدث لان لانني لا لان روسيا
لا تستطيع ان تتعامل مع وضع تتعرض فيه
سوريا لضربه عسكريه وبالتالي لا يجب تجنب
الضربه العسكريه عندما بدات عندما بدا
البحث بالتفاصيل طالما ان العرض قد قد
اصبح على الطاوله وبدا البحث بالتفاصيل
طبعا يعني لابد من الذهاب الى اقصى ما
يمكن عمله في مثل هذه
الحالات هذه حاله لا يمكن ان تتم الا تحت
البند السابع لان انه يجب ادخال ادخال
مفتشين ويجب طلب طلب اوراق من من من
الوزارات المختصه من الدوائر المختصه
يجب يعني مداهمه اماكن مشتبه فيها بان
هناك مواد كيماويه خزنت فيها يعني هذا كله
لا يتم تحت البند السادس لذلك التفاصيل هي
التي هي التي صنعت اليوم الوضع الحالي ثم
ان
بوتين عندما
عندما قدم هذا هذا هذا العرض قالت المصادر
الروسيه انه انقذ اوباما من امكانيه ان
يخسر تصويت في الكونغرس وانه انه القى له
خشبه الخلاص ولكن بنفس الوقت عندما قال
بوتين اليوم ان ان هذا العرض لا يمكن هذه
المبادره لا يمكن ان ان ان تقدم وتتم الا
اذا صحب اي صحبت التهديدات بضربه بضربه
عسكريه اعتقد بان هذا اعاد الى حد ما شيء
من ال انعش الى حد ما يعني فكره ان ان
الكونغرس يمكن ان يصوت في هذه الحال ولو
بفارق بسيط تصويتا لتحدي ال الاراده
الروسيه ط سيد كليمانس وزير الخارجيه
السوري وليد المعلم اكد مره اخرى اليوم
بان سوريا مستعده للكشف عن مخزونها من
الاسلحه الكيماويه وقف انتاج هذه الماده
والمبادره الروسيه فيما قدمت بمراحلها
الثلاثه تكلم عن هذه المراحل اذا لما
الخشيه من ان يتم هذا عن طريق البند
السابع على مستوى مجلس
الامن اعتقد انه تحت الفصل السابع كما قال
السيد بدر خان يعني ان سوريا هي الدوله
كان لها الكثير من الخداع والمراوغه في
السابق ونكران استخدام السلاح الكيمياوي
على عكس ما يعتقد تقريبا عالم برمته الذي
يعتقد ان النظام السوري استخدم هذا السلاح
ضد ابناء شعبه وقتل
1429 منهم اكثر من 400 طفل اذا هناك قدر
كبير من المراوغه والخداع التي تجعلنا
نشعر
كامريكا حيال الحكومه السوريه لذلك مساله
تحدي اين مكان هذه الاسلحه واين هي
الاعلانات والى اين اخذت ووزعت وخبئت لان
خزين الاسلحه الكيمياويه لا يتبقى في مكان
واحد وهناك كميات كبيره من هذا السلاح
داخل سوريا موزعه في انحاء البلاد اذا
هناك مخاوف حقيقيه من انه في اي مرحله
انتقاليه هذه الاسلحه قد تقع بايدي لاعبين
من غير الدول لذلك ف كل من مفتشي الامم
المتحده ووكالات انفاذ مثل هذه الاتفاقيات
تقع على وقها مسؤوليه كبيره لمراقبه الى
اين يمكن اخذ هذه الاسلحه الى ايادي
لاعبين اخرين وفي مثل هذه الحاله فان
الفصل السابع هو المطلوب للتعامل مع هذه
الامور لكن دعوني اضيف نقطه مهمه هنا حول
كيفيه بدء هذه القضيه اعتقد ان اداره
اوباما كانت تغازل نوعا
ما وايضا ترقص حوالي فكره معينه من دون ان
تاخذ على محمل الجد تقول ان اسد بشار
الاسد ماش في طريق لا ينفع معه الا
استخدام القوه ثم قيل لاعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
ان لا يبحثوا عن ايه بدائل لما يقترحوا
البيت الابيض احد هؤلاء الشيوخ السناتور
مانشن
قدم مشروع قرار بديل في الاسبوع الماضي
قال فيه ان العمل العسكري ربما يؤجل مؤقتا
لمده 45 يوما ما لم تقوم الحكومه
الامريكيه وحلفائها باقناع سوريا
بالانضمام الى معاهده حضر الاسلحه
الكيمياويه عندما ذكرت روسيا او قامت بذكر
هذه الفكره كان هناك شهيه في الكونجرس
لقبولها نوعا ما طيب استاذ عبد الوهاب
اعيد صياغ سؤالي بطريقه مختلفه عن مساله
البند السابع والمحاذير الروسيه من هذا
البند لماذا تحذر روسيا مادام ان دمشق
تبدي استعدادها الكامل التعاطي بايجابيه
مع المبادره الروسيه ما هي المحاذير ما هي
الحسابات الروسيه لان لان البند السابع
سيتضمن تهديدات وسيتضمن عقوبات في حال
انتهاك سوريا للقرار والانتهاكات ستحصل
لان احدا لا يع
اين هو مخزون المواد الكيماويه مصادر
المعارضه لديها على الاقل 30 مكانا جرى
فيها تخزين مواد كيماويه وهي وثقتها و
ومستعده لتقديم لوائح بها
اذا مثل هذه الدول هي مفطوره على المراوغه
لا يمكن الوثوق بان النظام سيسلم كل شيء
وبالتالي يجب اذا اذا ا كنت تريد ان تقوم
بعمليه لتفكيك ترسانه معينه لابد من ان
يكون لديك
كامل الحريه في الذهاب الى الاماكن وفي
التفتيش عن السجلات وغير ذلك تحت البند
السادس فقط اعتقد فقط يمكن الوثوق او يمكن
التعامل مع السلطات من دون ان ان ان ان
تخشى اي عقاب او اي مسائله فيما
بعد عفوا تفضل
تفضل لا انتهيت انا من هذا اوكي طيب سيد
كليمونس في ظل او في حال ما اذا تم فعلا
تمرير المبادره الروسيه وتم القبول بها هل
تشكل بديل للضربه العسكريه
واهدافها اعتقد ان هذه ان هذه نقطه مهمه
وسؤال وجيه للغايه توقعاتي انا ربما مثل
هذا التوقع لا يحظى بشعبيه كبيره اقول
اننا اذا ما استطعنا اقناع الاسد بالتخلي
عن سلاح الكيمياوي
ونقل سوريا الى حظيره الامم التي تحترم
اتفاقيه حظر الاسلحه
الكيمياويه الحرب الاهليه في سوريا ستنسى
والولايات المتحده ستسمي ما يجري
انتصارا والرئيس اوباما عندما تحرك بعد
هجوم الحدي من اب اغسطس تحرك بهامش ضيق
قائلا ان مهمتنا ليست تغيير النظام ولا
الاطاحه بالاسد فقط الرد على تحدي السلاح
الكيمياوي وتقويض قدره النظام للاستمرار
في ذلك اما الروس فتقدموا بمبادره ايضا
ضيقه وراينا كيف ان في خضم هذا الجدل
مساله الحرب الاهليه والقضيه برمتها قد
طرحت جانبا لذلك انا اتوقع اننا اذا ما
نجحنا في صفقه السلاح الكيمياوي لن تكون
هناك ضربه امريكيه وربما نرى ان بشار
الاسد سيخرج منتصرا من حرب الاهليه وربما
الروس يحسبون حساباتهم على هذا الاساس بما
ان الشيطان قد قفز في التفاصيل في هذا
اليوم فيما يتعلق بالمبادره الروسيه
والنقاش الحاصل الان على مستوى مجلس الامن
ماذا عن هذه المبادره وتعاطي الدول
الغربيه في حال التطورات المقبله سنناقشها
بعد الفاصل باذن
[موسيقى]
الله اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش ردود الفعل الغربيه على اقتراح
اخضاع اسلحه دمشق الكيميائيه للرقابه
الدوليه واجدد التحيه بضيفي هنا في
الاستوديو وكذلك في واشنطن استاذ عبد
الوهاب عن هذا الجدل الحاصل الان هل تراه
هامشي يمكن تجاوزه ام انه في الصلب
وبالتالي توقع مفاجات اخرى يعني هذا يتوقف
على المفهوم الذي س يعتمد
لتجاوز ال الازمه اذا اذا اعتمد الرئيس
اوباما على مفهوم انه
حصر المساله في
معاقبه النظام السوري على على استخدام
السلاح الكيماوي وجاءت المبادره الروسيه
تقترح ان هذا السلاح سناخذ وندم وفقا ل
اليه معينه وفقا لقرار مجلس الامن ولكن من
دون عقوبات من دون تهديد من دون البند
السابع في هذه
الحاله هو نفسه الرئيس اوباما لم يحدد
هدفا اخر
ل الضربات العسكريه وبالتالي فان الضربات
العسكريه تصبح بالنسبه اليه خيار لا لا
داعي له من هنا ان ان ان هناك امكانيه
بالجدل داخل مجلس الامن الى التوصل للتوصل
الى الى حل لماذا لان كل الدول تعاني من
الراي من الراي العام لديها الرافض لاي
تدخل عسكري كل الدول هناك انقسامات داخل
البرلمانات لاسباب تتعلق ب ب
بمسائل يعني عسكريه
ووساوس التجربه العراقيه وغير ذلك ولكن
تتعلق ايضا باسقاط على السياسه الداخليه
اذا هناك هناك سعي او هناك تمني لدى كل
الحكومات لتجاوز هذه الازمه واذا كانت
تجاوز هذه الازمه بثمن مثل سحب السلاح
الكيماوي وتفكيكه وتدميره فيما بعد فاعتقد
بان بالنسبه الى الى الاداره الام امريكيه
هذه تسويه معقوله لذلك من هنا ان ان انه
يؤسف له ان ما قالت ما قاله الائتلاف
السوري اليوم صحيح و وكيف تختزل المساله
فقط
بان كل المساله السوريه تختزلها فقط بان
النظام استخدم سلاحا كيماويا والسؤال
الاخر هو اليس ما حصل جريمه وكيف يمكن
تجاوزها من دون اي اي عقاب هذه هذان
السؤالان سيبقيان معلقين يعني سيد كليمنس
الى اي مدى ان من يؤثر الان وله الكلمه
النهائيه فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري عموما
وما يتعلق بالاسلحه الكيمائيه الان هو
الروس من يقود الحافله الان هم الروس وان
الدول الغربيه ماهم الا مجموعه ركاب ويجب
التركيز على السائق وليس على
الركاب اعتقد اننا راينا ولمده من الزمن
ليس فقط في فتره هذه هذا هذا المقترح
الروسي ان روسيا كانت متفوقه وروسيا حصلت
على بعض الزخم حتى قبل واثناء وبعد قمه
الع في التصدي الولايات المتحده وخاصه
بعدما راوا نتيجه التصويت في البرلمان
البريطانيا ان الغرب ليست لديه شهيه لحرب
جديده لذلك الروس
يعتقدون انهم هم الذين يكسبون الموقف
وبالنسبه للولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وبريطانيا يمكن هز مواقفهم بسهوله وايضا
الروس يرون مكانتهم الدوليه تتعزز وربما
اصبحوا الان هم الذين يقودون زمام
المبادره حتى منتصف الطريق على الاقل
لتحقيق حل ومبادر وايضا ايران التي لم
نتطرق اليها
تبدو مؤيده هذه المبادره رغم ان صدام حسين
قتل الكثيرين من الايرانيين بهذه الغازات
لذلك ربما نرى تطور ان يتحقق على هذا
الاساس وعبد الوهاب محق في رايه من ان
الجدل حول السلاح الكيميائي
واستعماله قد غير نحى جانبا الصور اليوميه
فيما يحدث يوميا من معانه في الحرب
الاهليه السوريه وبعدها عن دائره اهتمام
الاعلام وتطورات الاوضاع حول الوضع في
سوريا كلها تتركز حول مساله واحده وه ماذا
سيكون مصير هذا السلاح الكيمياوي ولدي
شعور باننا اذا ما نجحنا وحققنا هذه
المعجزه في سوريا
وهذا ربما يجعل من المستحيل لسوريا التخلص
من سلاح الكيميائي بطريقه يمكن التحقق
منها بحيث يجعل الولايات المتحده من غير
المرجح لها ان تستمر في لعب اي دور لازاحه
بشار الاسد من سده الحكم باي طريقه اخرى
اعتقد ان هذه هي فحوى الصفقه استاذ عبد
الوهاب تتكلم الدول الغربيه وعلى راسها
واشنطن عن اسباب استراتيجيه واخلاقيه دفعت
بها الى ما فعلته في الايام الماضيه وهددت
به هل تعرف واشنطن على سبيل المثال ما
تريد في الملف السوري وتحديدا ما يتعلق
باستعمال الكيماوي
برايك يعني احد
الماخذ الاساسيه على رئيس اوباما ان انه
ليس لديه استراتيجيه هو فقط تحدث عن ضربات
محدوده ولا يزال الحديث عن ضربات محدوده
وبالتالي ف احد الماخذ هو انه الى اين الى
اين انت ذاهب هل انت ذاهب الى اضعاف
النظام فقط الى الى وخذ وخذه دبوس كما كما
قال تشاك هاجل عندما عندما قال انها لن
تكون كوخز الدب بوس ام انت ذاهب فعلا الى
خلخله المعادله وبالتالي التوصل الى نوع
من التوازن الميداني ما بين المعارضه
وقوات النظام وعند ذلك يمكن
طرح الحل السياسي على فكره يعني عندما
عرضت الافكار بين الامريكيين والروس خلال
الاتصالات كان هناك محوران المحور الاول
هو ماذا نفعل بمساله السلاح الكيمياوي
والمحور الثاني
كان كيف يمكن ازاله العقبات امام الحل
السياسي اذا نظرنا الى هذان هذين المحورين
يمكن ان نرى ان هناك فعلا خطه ان هناك
فعلا استراتيجيه ولكن في في هذين اليومين
لم يجري ابدا الحديث عن الحل السياسي جرى
الحديث فقط عن كيف نتفادى
الاحراج الذي حصل سواء للولايات المتحده
وحتى
للروس من استخدام السلاح ال الكيماوي
وبالتالي الجميع يريد ان يتعامل مع السلاح
وليس مع ما فعله السلاح لا مع مع ان هناك
سلاح كيماوي وليس مع ان هناك الاداس
الجاني وليس نعم وليس ان هناك
اي ضحايا ويمكن ان ان ان يسقط مزيد من
الضحايا في اي في اي في اي مناسبه اخرى
لان النظام سيستغل فعلا يعني الوقت الضائع
وربما يرتكب جري اخرى سيد كليمون سؤال
اخير وباختصار لو سمحت ماذا عن مؤتمر جنيف
ضمن او في ظل كل هذه التفاعلات ووصول هذا
الملف الى مجلس الامن وهذا النقاش
الدائر طبعا احدى نقاط الاختلاف الوديه مع
عبد الوهاب فقط اقول يوم امس ان سوزن رايس
مستشاره الامن القومي للرئيس اوباما وتون
بلينك ايضا مساعدها في كلامهم تحدثوا عن
ماهيه هذه الاستراتيجيه والتي تقول يجب
دعم ضربه
عسكريه محدده بحيث تقوض من قدرته على
استخدام السلاح الكيمياوي وتجعله او مضطرا
الى الذهاب الى مفاوضات جنيف هذه
التصريحات حدثت قبل المقترح الروسي اذا
سواء كنا نتفق مع الاستراتيج ام لا كان
يتحدثون عن واحده على
الاقل موجوده مازالت لكن الجميع يبدو انه
قد نس للاسف سيد كليمنس ادركنا الوقت
اشكرك السيد ستيف كليمنس رئيس تحرير مجله
ذ اتلانتك وكبير الباحثين في مؤسسه امريكا
الجديده كما اشكر ضيفي هنا في الاستديو
الكاتب الصحفي عبد الوهاب بدرخان شكرا
جزيلا لك بذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
س